et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre conesa ancien haut fonctionnaire
spécialiste des questions stratégiques
internationales bonsoir pierre connaît
sa merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france quand on voit ce sujet on se
demande jusqu'où la progression des
taliban peut-elle aller ils ont déjà
grignoté beaucoup de terrain alors que
les américains n'ont même pas encore
complètement quitté le pays
oui effectivement on va voir le scénario
qui est le retour des talibans au
pouvoir
le il est évident que si vous voulez
l'intrusion d'une tierce partie dans la
situation de l'afghanistan est
évidemment un phénomène perturbateurs
qui conduit pratiquement à lui lyon
gerland contre l'étranger
c'est assez paradoxal mais c'est comme
ça et deuxième chose l'état normal de
l'afghanistan c'est la crise c'est pas
la stabilité donc beaucoup de comment
dire d'étrangers que ce soit qu'ils
soient russes en 79 qu'ils soient
américains en 2002 ont toujours pensé
que leur simple arrivée la promesse du
régime qu'ils allaient installer
suffiraient à calmer ce qui est un état
de guerre civile at en afghanistan en
afghanistan est une gang opéra de chef
de guerre ces chefs de guerre dont
convocation que de défendre leur ethnie
et donc comme disait l'un d'entre eux
d'ailleurs est désert on peut pas
acheter la chef de guerre afghan
mais on peut le louer bon c'est beau ça
vous donne la vente à l'it et si vous
voulez du rapport à la violence dans
cette danse pays incapables de rétablir
la situation
l'autre aspect qui est extrêmement
important c'est la lassitude de
l'opinion publique américaine
c'est évidemment mais question suivante
c'est un échec patent de nous de cette
stratégie américaine tout ça pour ça
aussi bien voilà des vies perdues de
l'argent du temps pour arriver justement
a quasiment le point zéro
oui même si vous laissez le n'est pas le
seul exemple de résultats
catastrophiques de l'espèce du bri
guerrière qui s'est emparée les pays
occidentaux qui se sont créés en charge
de faire une espèce de police
internationale bon et donc l'essentiel
des interventions qui se sont d'ailleurs
concentrées conseil très concentré
pardon sur le moyen orient ont toutes
tourné
l'échec que ce soit en irak que ce soit
en afghanistan
encore une fois parce que la légitimité
de l'intervention occidentale elle peut
être motivée par de très bons moyens qui
nous paraissent nous significative mais
qui sont pris comme une invasion armée
nous parler par les habitants donc il
faut cesser de penser qu'on peut
résoudre des crises politique par des
moyens militaires
c'est par un conseil que je donne aux
dirigeants occidentaux
donc le bilan de dix ans ou 15 ans six
volets d'intervention militaire est
totalement négative
excepté la bosnie il ya eu aucun
résultat positif aujourd'hui clairement
que va devenir ce pays on imagine que
les talibans vont peut-être aller
jusqu'à la chute du gouvernement
d'ashraf ghani oui oui on peut tout à
fait le penser cela dit est ce que le
retour des talibans au pouvoir en
afghanistan suffira à stabiliser si vous
voulez encore une fois cet équilibre
instable qui est la situation de
l'afghanistan dont les talibans sont en
majorité des pachtouns c'est-à-dire de
l'ethnie dominante mais ils ne sont pas
seuls en mesure de contrôler la totalité
du territoire donc on sera dans une
espèce d'état de paix armée simplement
tout ce qu'on peut espérer c'est qu'on
canalise si vous voulez cette violence
pour empêcher qu'elle ne diffuse sur la
périphérie
il ya eu pourtant des négociations entre
américains et talibans est ce que
c'était ce qu'il fallait faire c'était
la bonne stratégie
ça a été fait comme une espèce de
préparation au départ c'est à dire pour
montrer que washington était prêt à
s'asseoir à une table de négociation
avec ses pires ennemis
et puis effectivement l'intention
n'était pas la même des deux côtés c'est
à dire washington n'étaient pas décidés
à rester jusqu'à l'issue des
négociations puisque finalement le
retrait a été annoncée déjà en partie un
parent trap est effectivement parler
d'elle donc on est effectivement la
situation c'était une pseudo
négociations qui devaient permettre de
partir disons un peu dignement pour les
troupes américaines mais c'est une
véritable catastrophe un cd v dont
l'armée afghane a pourtant été formés
pendant donc c
et l'ont emmenée par l'armée américaine
ça veut dire qu'il n'en reste rien
pourquoi elles sont si compliqués c'est
compliqué parce qu'encore une fois si
vous voulez un afghan à deux
appartenances ebay d'afghans et en même
temps il va être pachtounes tadjiks qui
va être ce que vous voulez c'est rouler
à rien c'est une mosaïque d'ethnies
l'afghanistan et n'oubliez pas que c'est
une zone de confort entre les empires
c'est à dire d'avant droit dans ce
qu'elles se sont réfugiés dans le dans
toute la chaîne de la douche tout des
populations qui étaient persécutés à
droite et à gauche donc ce n'est pas un
pays ce n'est pas une nation
l'afghanistan c'est un espèce d'état
tampon qui s'était constitué entre l'
empire engueuler empire russe etc et
donc toutes ces populations ont appris à
se défendre elle même il se défendre
elle même ça veut dire se défendent
éventuellement contre d'autres city donc
il faut pas qu'on arrive nous en disant
nous avons la solution rappelez vous la
solution bhl qui ce président commandant
massoud comme la solution c'était une
espèce d'escroquerie intellectuelle
personne ne peut penser que a fortiori
un tadjik minorité minorité en
afghanistan allait assurer le pouvoir
central en afghanistan dont on est
encore une fois sur cette logique on
croit que nous occidentaux on va imposer
un modèle d'état et quand même rappelez
vous cette extraordinaire annonce si
vous voulez qu'on allait faire la base
que les américains avaient trouvé c'est
à dire d'annoncer justifier la guerre
d'afghanistan pour libérer la femme
afghane
bon pour ceux qui ont bien peu les pieds
en afghanistan ils savent très bien que
si vous explique un habitant nous a
libéré sa femme et sa fille vous êtes
sûr de vous en faire un ennemi d'envoyer
ce décalage psychologique politique
sociale etc conduisait à l'échec et
c'est de fait ce qui s'est passé que les
russes c'est ce qui se passera l'an
passé que les américains ce qui s'était
d'ailleurs pas c'est que les anglais au
19e siècle
merci beaucoup en tout cas pierre conesa
nous avoir apporté vos lumière sur cette
situation en afghanistan où les taliban
je le disais donc ne cessent de gagner
du terrain merci à vous